[Musik]
Land und Brecht
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich am
altbewährten Ort es war wieder zu Hause
finde ich gut viel unterwegs
so mitkriege irgendwo Vorträge in St
Gallen und sonst wo und dann verteidigst
du wieder welche klimakleber ist wieder
stark sein in der Schweiz als das
mitgekriegt nö habe ich gar nicht mehr
da jemand aufgeregt nein aber ich merke
wie dieses Thema die Leute so aufwühlt
und und wie es sie anzündet ich glaube
der Grund liegt einfach daran gegen
Fridays for future konnte man nichts
sagen ja und das also die Kinder und die
machen sich Sorgen ihre Zukunft und Sie
haben ja mit der ganzen Grundausrichtung
haben sie auch recht man könnte nur
sagen wir dürfen die Schule nicht
schwänzen so wie Christian Lindner aber
ansonsten konnte man nichts dagegen
sagen und jetzt hat man durch diese
Kleber Aktionen und wo man dann den Link
hergestellt hat hey da können ja
Menschenleben gefährdet werden
Verkehrsblockaden sind ja auch
gefährlich und so weiter zerstört werden
meinte ja genau wir haben ja ausführlich
darüber gesprochen und da hat man jetzt
aus konservativer Perspektive ein neues
Feindbild ja also der linke
klimaaktivist der wird jetzt mit der AF
gleichgesetzt und diese Übertreibung die
geht mir einfach zu weit ja also ich
habe ein anderes Problem damit ich ich
habe das Gefühl das ganze Land ist
unvorstellbar gestresst und irgendwie
sind das immer noch Phantomschmerzen die
kommen aus dieser corona-zeit und so
weiter man merkt erst mal so allmählich
was ist dafür Verheerungen gegeben hat
das Leben ist irgendwie so anstrengend
geworden und dann kommt noch diese ganze
Debatte um um wärmewende und dann
versuchst du irgendwie dein Leben in
Griff zu kriegen und versuchst morgens
von A nach B zu fahren und die Kinder
einigermaßen pünktlich in der Schule
abzuliefern und dann gehst du zur Arbeit
und machst dein Ding und dann ist aber
auch noch Inflation die ganze Zeit und
es geht auch nicht weg und die Bahnen
fahren nicht genau und das denke das ist
nämlich der andere Punkt wenn man den
Leuten vorwerfen könnte pass auf ihr
seid einfach bequeme Säcke ihr wollt
einfach Autofahren dabei geht es doch
sowas großartiges wie den ÖPNV und die
Bahn und so weiter das ist ja alles
nicht so wir wollen alles so gleichen
Zeit und merken gar nicht dass wir das
Land dass wir die Menschen unfassbar
überfordern und dann gehen auch noch
Leute hin und kleben sich morgens
während du dann dann dein Kind gerade in
die Schule weil sie den letzten Reste
mein Thema ist was was bringt das der
Sache nichts ehrlich gesagt ich weiß gar
nicht wie ich anfangen soll und ich war
mir auch nicht sicher oder bin mir nicht
sicher ob wir darüber mal reden sollten
oder vielleicht sollten wir das mal
einfach mal machen das
Erregungspotenzial weil wir auch gerade
über angestaute Aggressionen ja
genau diese diese diese diese diese
unvorstellbare Gereiztheit und er hat
nicht nur was mit den sommerlichen
schwülen Temperaturen zu tun sie sich
noch mal ja geht das noch mal nach oben
wir sind in so einem in so einer Dauer
Erregtheit ja ja du nimmst das auch so
wahr ich nehme das absolut war und und
wenn man Ursachen Forschung macht ne
sich vor warum ist unsere Gesellschaft
so irrsinnig gereizt dann fällt einem so
vieles auf einmal ein und es fällt einem
auch überhaupt nicht ein warum diese
Gereiztheit jemals wieder weggehen
sollte ich habe also nicht das Gefühl
das ist eine Phase sondern ich habe das
Gefühl irgendwie unsere immer
komplizierter werdende Umwelt auch die
Beschleunigung all der Dinge in unserem
Leben tragen dazu bei dass diese
Gereiztheit unglaublich zunimmt ich
frage mich welche Rolle wir dabei
spielen diese diese diese diese
Dauerschleife diese Dauer Erregtheit je
nicht mehr jeden Tag einen neuen Skandal
alle halbe Stunden neuen Skandal ich
denke da gerade zum Beispiel an die
Vorgänge auch rund um Rammstein das
Erregungspotenzial darum ich meine jetzt
mal ganz unabhängig davon was da
wirklich war und
möglicherweise sind das schlimme Dinge
passiert und möglicherweise sind junge
Frauen zu opfern geworden und es wurden
ihnen ohne ihr Wissen kautopfen
eingeflößt und es ist äh es ist zu
Vergewaltigung oder was auch immer
gekommen ich will nur sagen das ist doch
die Aufgabe von Staatsanwälten von
Gerichten das zu klären und dann
gegebenenfalls den Täter die Täter zur
Rechenschaft zu ziehen ja aber was ich
mittlerweile wie soll man sagen mit mit
zum wirklich nur noch mulmigen Gefühl
verfolge ist ist die Art und Weise wie
schnell wir dann medial dabei sind
erstens alles zu wissen in einer
atemberaubenden Geschwindigkeit und dann
auch das Urteil klar zu haben und wenn
das mediale Urteil erst gesprochen ist
dann ist es im Nachgang ehrlich gesagt
fast egal was das eigentliche das
juristische Urteil war wenn das mediale
Urteil gesprochen ist bist du erledigt
das wärst du nicht mehr von dir ab ja
also in das wäre ja ein berühmtes
Beispiel ist ja Kachelmann über einen
langen langen Zeitraum medial vorurteilt
worden wo sich weiß ich wer da alles zu
Wort gemeldet hat und eine Schauer
Geschichte jagte die nächsten und alles
schwarzer wusste schon ganz ganz genau
was das der Prototyp eines Vergewaltiger
es ist und und und und und dann im
Nachhinein wird er frei gesprochen
und trotzdem ist dieses Image war das
nicht der und so weiter und die Hälfte
aller Leute kennt ihn vom Wetter und die
andere Hälfte kennt ihn wegen dieser
Schlagzeilen das heißt also du kannst ja
noch so oft duschen du wirst das nicht
mehr los und wenn man sich überlegt was
da angerichtet wird durch mediale
Vorverurteilung müsste man ja eigentlich
die Konsequenz haben und sagen
vorsichtig darüber berichten ja
vielleicht auch nicht gerade den Titel
Geschichte draus zu machen wenn die
Staatsanwaltschaft gerade erst mit den
Ermittlungen beginnt und wir eben die
ganzen Zusammenhänge und das Ausmaß gar
nicht kennen
aber in letzter Zeit häuft sich das der
Spiegel hatte vor einigen Wochen ein
Heft der hat ja vier Seiten über Til
Schweiger gehabt in also als als
kompletten Unmenschen dargestellt hat
und über den Koch Christian Jürgens bei
dem genau das gleiche war also acht
Seiten in einer Zeitung wie der Spiegel
Zeitschrift wie der Spiegel die für sich
Qualität in Anspruch nimmt oder
siriosität
in beiden Fällen lagen zu dem Zeitpunkt
keinerlei Strafanzeigen vor deshalb
wurde gar nicht gerichtlich ermittelt es
war also stand also kein echter
Straftatbestand im Raum und dann eine
komplette vorurteilung zu machen und
aufgrund von Zeugenaussagen die völlig
richtig sein können aber nicht müssen
Punkt
genau warum warum macht man das also da
ist doch irgendeine Hemmschwelle die
früher mal in den Medien da war
jedenfalls in der sogenannten
Qualitätspresse die ist da gefallen
ja ich hängt gerade noch mal
Jörg Kachelmann nach ja gedanklich ich
erinnere mich an ein Gespräch mit mit
einer muss man schon sagen an einer
pathologie-legende ja legendäre
Hamburger Gerichtsmediziner dr Püschel
Professor Püschel Instanz hier in
Hamburg gewesen es mittlerweile im
Ruhestand war dann auch mal bei mir in
der Sendung interessanter Mann der
ganz früh schon in der ersten
corona-phase angefangen hat Menschen
zusätzlichen die an Corona gestorben
sind und der dann sehr früh auch sagte
Vorsicht vorsicht diese Menschen sind
nicht unbedingt an Corona die sind zum
Teil auch mit Corona gestorben und so
weiter das war einer von von denjenigen
die sehr früh auch den Zweifel hatten ob
das die Tod bringen der Krankheit
wirklich ist von der wir lange Zeit
dachten dass sie es ist und der dann
auch darauf hinwies und sagte passt auf
das ist eine gefährliche Krankheit aber
es gibt bestimmte Merkmale die ich dann
immer wieder sehe zum Beispiel sehr
übergewichtige Menschen die dann ein
besonderes Problem kriegen und so weiter
das hat er alles bei sich auf dem
Seziertisch da gesehen und der und ich
habe nach der Sendung ich darf das mal
ausplaudern ein Gespräch mit ihm geführt
genau über den Fall über Jörg Kachelmann
und er sagte ich habe mir diese Bilder
angesehen die Beweismittel sozusagen für
diese
vermeintliche Vergewaltigung dieser
angebliche Vergewaltigung der sagte
anhand dieser Bilder hätten wir hier in
Hamburg niemals ein Verfahren eröffnet
niemals weil diese Bilder gaben das
nicht her es war völlig klar dass das
Verfahren ist am Ende eröffnet worden
wegen des medialen Drucks
ich sag mal so ich auch da kann man nur
spekulieren aber man hat schon das
Gefühl
da gibt es eben genau dass das was ich
meine dieses ungute Zusammenspiel
sozusagen aus aus Justiz und am Ende
auch Medien
ich muss jetzt aufpassen wie ich
formuliere aber auf eine Art ein sich
durchaus auch selbst erhalten des System
wenn es schlecht läuft ein gutes System
wenn es sozusagen
wechselseitig dafür sorgt dass der ein
oder andere den Job macht aber das kann
eine fatale suchwirkung nach unten
entfalten wenn man das Gefühl hat okay
da habe ich jetzt das jetzt ein ganz
berühmter Mann das könnte der Fall
meines Lebens werden und den bringen wir
jetzt zur Strecke so ich kann zitieren
der sagte wir hätten wir hätten das Ding
niemals zu Anklage gebracht weil es war
völlig klar das ist ganz ganz dünnes Eis
und dann haben sie sich da immer tiefer
rein verrannt ja die die
Staatsanwaltschaft Mannheim war das
glaube ich und haben immer weiter
gemacht und weiter gemacht und am Ende
war das ja auch jetzt nicht irgendein
Freispruch sondern es war ein 1A
Freispruch wie man das dann so so so
laienhaft nennt ja das war nicht jetzt
aus Mangel an Beweisen sondern sondern
völlig klar und das was da behauptet
wurde das ist nie passiert das hat so
nie stattgefunden schlicht untergreifend
ja oder denkt doch mal daran dass die
Hetzjagd auf Christian Wulff ja also das
hat ja über lange Zeit gab es ja kein
anderes Thema in der Gesellschaft und
ich war von Anfang an dagegen dass
Christian Wolf Bundespräsident wird und
die Begründung dafür war er war
Ministerpräsident gewesen war sein Leben
lang so eine rein politische Biografie
gehabt
war in dieser Zeit durch nichts ganz
besonders aufgefallen und dachte sich so
mit 50 oh jetzt mal nach Berlin und
Bundespräsident werden ist doch super
und Merkel dachte sich wenn der
Bundespräsident wird wird er mir nicht
mehr gefährlich so das fand ich jetzt
nicht angemessen ja ich bin sowieso der
Meinung Bundespräsidenten das sollte
nicht ausgediente Politiker machen
sondern das sollten deutsche werden die
sich in der Zivilgesellschaft verdient
gebracht haben das ist meine Ansicht die
habe ich auch damals präsentiert und
habe in diesem Kontext damals sowohl im
Spiegel wie in der Zeit lange es Hells
geschrieben die sich gegen diesen
Kandidaten ausgesprochen haben das heißt
also ich hatte keine Sympathien für ihn
es ist dann losging mit seinem
häuserkredit und dir deine Hexenjagd
entbrannt ist bisschen am Ende zum Bobby
Car und so irgendeiner Hotelrechnung wo
irgendjemand mal 200 oder 300 € für ihn
bezahlt hat und Filmproduzent
ich meine das war eine Hexenjagd
unglaublichen Ausmaßes jeder die da
stattfand dazu wurde ja noch seine
Lebensgefährtin den uns hier etwas was
ja dann dazu geführt hat dass Günther
Jauch dann in der Talkshow gefragt hat
ob es stimmt dass die Bild-Zeitung seine
Frau wegen deren Vergangenheit erpresst
und damit wurde die ganze Sache
überhaupt erst in die Öffentlichkeit
gebracht ja da wurden also diese miesen
Gerüchte die da gestreut wurden auch
noch so geheiligt im Grunde genommen
was sind das für unfassbare Vorgänge die
damals waren und ich habe mich an alle
dem überhaupt nicht beteiligt weil ich
dachte hier wird einem Menschen der wie
mir wie gesagt nicht besonders
sympathisch weich hätte miteinander im
Bundespräsidenten gewählt der wird hier
mediat wegen King kardasien
abgeschlachtet und das war so die rote
hatte ne so richtig die Meute habe ich
auch geschrieben und heute ist hier der
richtige Ausdruck ja das sind wieder
drei Hunde die da so die Blutspur
aufgenommen haben und sagen wir finden
dann noch das entscheidende Detail über
das ja schließlich gefällt und dieses
Detail ist nie gefunden worden sondern
ist zurückgetreten war da die gesamte
Presse gegensichert das richtige
zurückgetreten weil er sein Image in der
Öffentlichkeit ruiniert war ohne dass
man allzu viel Brauchbares gefunden
hätte was dafür im Grund sein können
weißt du was ich an Christian Wulff so
bemerkenswert fand aber das nur ganz
kurz in Klammern was jetzt gar nicht das
Thema ist aber was ich interessant fand
war wir im entscheidenden Moment den
Rücken gerade gemacht hat der hatte ja
die Chance gegen sozusagen ein
Teilgeständnis was auch immer und dann
ein Bußgeld und so weiter auf seine
Verfahrenseinstellung und das hat er
nicht gemacht natürlich nicht sondern
hat sich gerade gemacht und hat gesagt
pass auf nein das ziehen wir jetzt mal
bis zum Ende durch das ist der eine Teil
den ich interessant finde an diesem Fall
ich finde aber auch den zweiten Teil
interessant und deswegen bin ich da
immer so ein bisschen hin und
hergerissen weißt du ich komme aus einem
Land in dem gerade sind wir beides Koni
gestorben ist und und der im Grunde
sozusagen den den den staatlich
legitimierten
Beschiss und Betrug eigentlich so
richtig gesellschaftsfähig gemacht hat
das war immer so das war nicht so das
Ding guck mal wie peinlich ist das denn
wieder und was für eine Sauerei ist und
das wieder sondern es war irgendwann das
Gefühl hätte das ist ja ein wahnsinnig
smarter Typ warum kommt er mit alledem
davon so gerissen wäre ich auch gerne
das war irgendwann das Gefühl und dieses
Gefühl da wurde Politik zur Unterhaltung
ja aber
nein aber aus der in der rezeptions
Perspektive dass er eine Menge Mist
angerichtet hat ist das eine aber er
wurde von vielen Leuten so unter dem
Gesicht und das hatte heute wieder
lustiges gemacht ja ja ja und so weiter
also muss man
aber ja was für ein cooler sagt
ausgeschlafen ja dass er das alles macht
und so weiter und auch die Steuer
Hinterziehung und der hervorragend die
Kamera der Minister und so und alle wie
Geschwister und alles geht so irgendwie
durch und am Ende sagt man aber ganz
bewundern tut also
das wieder gemacht hat das wüsste ich
auch gerne mal und und so gerissen wäre
ich auch gerne mal und diese diese
Stimmung diese Atmosphäre ist in
Deutschland so nie entstanden und
Christian Wulff war eben ne ich glaube
dieses ganze Verfahren hat ungefähr 20
Millionen gekostet also Steuerzahler 20
Millionen muss man sich mal vorstellen
und das wurde gemacht und am Ende kommt
an Bobby Car dabei raus und ich habe oft
gedacht was für ein Wahnsinn und
gleichzeitig aber auch wie gut weil es
für jeden der in politischen
Spitzenämtern ist wirklich der
sachdienliche Hinweis ist versucht erst
gar nicht wir haben euch auf dem Schirm
und wir werden euch notfalls auch zur
Rechenschaft ziehen und deswegen haben
wir glaube ich in Deutschland eine
weitestgehend nicht korrupte politische
Klasse was ein riesiges
ein riesiger Vorteil dieses Landes ist
also Markus wenn du sagst das Positive
daran ist dass man heute als Politiker
eigentlich keine Chance mehr hat korrupt
zu sein falls das stimmen sollte
aber um welchen Preis erkauft ja dann
den Preis erkauft das auf der auf der
anderen Seite Kleinigkeiten
Kinkerlitzchen zu einer generellen
misstrauenserklärung führen bis hin dazu
dass die das Image eines Menschen
vollständig runterzuputzen das ist im
Fall von Christian Wulff passiert ja
mein Punkt war aber gerade der
juristische Teil ne ich ich finde es gut
dass wir eine Justiz haben die hinguckt
das finde ich gut weil das Gegenteil
davon ist Bunga Bunga und ich finde es
gut dass das noch mal die juristische
Seite was medial dann daraus wird und
wie sich das verselbstständigt und
welche welche horrenten Schlagzeilen das
dann nach sich zieht und und dich dann
so zerstört was dann dann dann Bild in
der Öffentlichkeit angeht dass du dich
eigentlich am besten nie wieder irgendwo
blicken lassen lässt ja das ist steht
auf dem ganz anderen Blatt aber die
juristische genau hin zu gucken ich sag
mal Italien hätte er es gut getan wenn
die in all den Jahren sehr genau
hingeguckt hätten mittlerweile tun sie
es und es tut im Land erkennbar gut ja
also ich bin weiß dass juristische
anbelangt absolut auf deiner Seite was
das mediale anbelangt habe ich folgende
these also ich frage mal folgende
Hypothese man wird sich die Frage stellt
warum sind diese
Hinrichtungen diese Vorverurteilung also
im Fall Till Lindemann im Fall von Til
Schweiger damals im Fall von Kachelmann
im Fall von Christian Wulff also wenn
der ganze Reihe von solchen Fällen
aufzählen warum sind die so extrem warum
beteiligen sich so viele daran und warum
ist das so ein medienfest jemand
öffentlich zu schlachten der Fragen
damals
klar Medien brauchen Auflage Konkurrenz
und sozialen Netzwerken und so weiter
das spielt sich ja eine Rolle aber wenn
man so ein bisschen tiefert und sich
fragt warum macht man das wir leben ja
doch eigentlich in einer Gesellschaft in
der wir gezwungenermaßen immer
anständiger werden gezwungenermaßen
dadurch weil politische Korrektheit
heute sehr viel schärfer sanktioniert
wird als im früheren Zeiten da ist das
zum Teil gar nicht funktioniert worden
und heute muss man sich richtig
ausdrücken macht ganz schnell irgendeine
Formulierung die gegen einen verwendet
werden kann als sexistisch oder
rassistisch und so weiter das heißt also
muss jedes Wort auf die Goldwaage legen
das hat durchaus Vorteile es hat aber
auch Nachteile und der Nachteil ist dass
ich in der Gesellschaft wenn man viele
Dinge nicht mehr klar aussprechen kann
das was man sozusagen wie man sie
normalerweise aussprechen würde dann
staut sich immer mehr an und dieses
angestaute das darf man dann rauslassen
wenn die Medien jemand zum öffentlichen
abschusspreis gegeben haben und dann ja
dann wird sozusagen kompensatorisch da
hat einer die Regel nicht eingehalten ja
was ich jetzt unter Zwang und Druck und
nörgel machen muss ja und der hat's
nicht und dann ist das so entlastend
weil dann brauche ich mich überhaupt
nicht mehr zusammenreißen auf den kann
ich schimpfen und einschlagen und den
fertig machen und so
bis ich dann wieder so auftanken kann
und dann wieder muss ich dann wieder
aufpassen dass ich nichts sage und so
also ich glaube das hat der
Entlastungsfunktion und das erinnert
mich sehr stark ans Mittelalter ja diese
öffentlichen Hinrichtungen auf
aufmerkten oder jemand an einen Pranger
stellen da wird jemand anderenfall
gebunden und alle dürfen vorbei gehen ja
und dürfen den anspucken
und das ist so ein bisschen das was ihr
im Augenblick passiert da bricht sich so
so ein acharisches Bedürfnis bricht sich
der Bahn
also es ist total interessanter Punkt an
dem Du gerade bist also diese du meinst
diese politische Korrektheit führt auch
tatsächlich zu dieser berühmten
Verengung des des meinungskorridors also
leben wir wirklich in einer Gesellschaft
indem wir nicht mehr alles so sagen
dürfen naja also man darf natürlich
alles sagen aber muss natürlich schon
bei relativ kleinen Konformität sondern
Raum Verstößen mit sehr heftigen
Reaktion das meine ich und das führt
dann in der Konsequenz dazu dass dieses
Gefühl entsteht man kann und darf nicht
mehr alles sagen weil natürlich dürfen
wir das auf dem Papier wir haben
Meinungsfreiheit und ich natürlich
dürfen wir das auch unter Freunden und
das dürfen
zusammenstehen ja dürfen wir das
vielleicht auch wenn wir irgendwie
wissen die sind ja jetzt da auch nicht
so übersensibel oder so aber wir dürfen
müssen zumindestens wenn wir uns in der
Öffentlichkeit befinden sehr sehr sehr
genau formulieren weil eine einzige
Formulierung kann schon ausreichen dass
sie medialis Feuerwerk einfach wird ich
habe meine Studie in die Hände gekriegt
von zwei Sozialwissenschaftlern Matthias
Revers und Richard Traunmüller die eine
Studie gemacht haben über die
Beschränkung der Redefreiheit dies im
September 2020 erschienen in einer
Kölner zeitschrift für Sozialpsychologie
und haben sich Hochschulen angeguckt
genau zu dem Thema und der wirklich
traurige Befund knapp 1.000 befragte
Studenten aus dem mehrheitlich linken
Spektrum möchten gar nicht erst mit
divergierenden Ansichten wie es dann da
so schön heißt behelligt werden und die
Hälfte der Befragten ist sogar dagegen
Redner mit abweichenden Meinungen zu den
Themen Islam Geschlecht und Zuwanderung
an der Hochschule zu Duden noch höher
ist der Anteil derer die abweichland
keine lehrbuchung ist zugestehen und
wiederum ein Drittel möchte dass diese
Bücher also Bücher solche Leute aus den
Bibliotheken verschwinden
das ist irre das ist wirklich irre dass
man im Namen der Toleranz argumentiert
dass man aber intolerant gegenüber
anderen Meinungen diesbezüglich ist und
das nimmt zu und das nimmt auch leider
bei intelligenten Menschen zu und ich
glaube man macht sich da natürlich ganz
ganz viele Gedanken um seine eigene
Befindlichkeit aber man macht sich zu
wenig Gedanken was aus einer
Gesellschaft wird wo sich das dann
durchsetzt zumal diese Gruppe von der du
gerade gesprochen hast nicht die
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung ist
ich finde es sehr schlimm wenn sie es
wäre ja ich finde jede Gesellschaft
schlimm die andere Meinungen
grundsätzlich nicht mehr toleriert oder
die ihre roten Linien dessen was sie für
zumutbare politische Überzeugung halten
immer enger und immer enger schneit es
am Ende nur noch die eigene politische
Überzeugung übrig bleibt das finde ich
grundsätzlich schlimm selbst wenn es die
Mehrheit der Gesellschaft wäre aber in
diesem Fall ist es ja auch noch so dass
das eine relativ kleiner Kreis von
Menschen ist der aber kulturell sehr
wirkungsmächtig ist aber wo wo führt
denn das hin Richard ich meine auf der
einen Seite diese Hyper Empörung und auf
der anderen Seite sozusagen dieses
duckmäuserische dieses nicht ansprechen
was wirklich ist die schwierigen Themen
lieber außen vor lassen ich ich merke
das auch immer wenn ich wenn ich in der
Sendung sitze ja wenn wenn wir bestimmte
Themen plötzlich Streifen dann merke ich
wie wie sich Leute schon zum Teil halb
in ihren Stuhl rein ducken weil sie bloß
nicht möchten dass diese Frage zum weiß
ich nicht zu einem schwierigen
Tatbestand
Thema Migration Thema Probleme bei der
Integration von Menschen zum Beispiel
Überforderung der Gesellschaft selbst
darüber zu reden fällt so vielen
unendlich schwer das Schwierige ist das
sowohl als auch Meinungen die man zu
solchen Themen ja haben kann wo man also
sagen kann natürlich gibt es Menschen
Migrationshintergrund die straffällig
werden und man darf muss ich die Frage
stellen warum darf das dann nicht
benannt werden und so weiter am Ende
muss man damit rechnen dass irgendeiner
Äußerung die man gemacht hat ohne dass
man das in ein Kontext gestellt hat und
so weiter so die kontextualisiert
irgendwo zitiert wird und dafür haben
die Menschen ganz große Angst ja du
sagst ein Satz zu dem Du dann nachher
auch noch relativierendes sagst sondern
wirst in die rechte Ecke gestellt oder
in irgend andere Ecke gestellt unsere
Medien sind ja sehr gut darin jemand in
irgendwelche Ecken zu stellen oder
irgendwelchen Lagern zugehörig fühlen
oder so oder genau zu wissen dass jemand
irgendetwas ganz schlimmes denkt er sagt
es nur nicht so richtig ne also diese
ganze haben wir neue die wir da
betreiben ne diese diese ganze Hobby
psychologisiererei ja was Menschen die
schlimmen bestimmte Menschen sind die
sich noch nicht so richtig trauen zu
sagen wie schlimm sie eigentlich sind
das ist etwas das ist ganz normal wann
ist uns das verrutscht wann sind wir wir
hatten das Thema öfter ich hat wann sind
wir so eine hochmoralische Gesellschaft
geworden waren dadurch dass die
Stammtische öffentlich wurden
also dadurch dass er die sozialen Medien
kam die sozialen Medien haben das was
sonst am Stammtisch rausgehauen ist und
was halt eben Wirtshaus geblieben ist ja
die Möglichkeit gehabt dass
millionenfach in die Welt hinauszubauen
und damit wurde auf einmal die
Privatmeinung irgendwelche Leute
gesellschaftlich relevant
und das hat dazu geführt dass man sehr
viel vorsichtiger sein muss was man tut
ja auch mal davon zu reden was gibt es
nicht alles für handyfotografen die
irgendwelche Szenen von irgendjemand
aufnehmen können und dann irgendwo
einspeisen wo wo irgendjemand mal
gepöbelt hat oder was weiß ich was oder
so das heißt also die Möglichkeit auch
der Überwachung Technologien
befindet sich immer wenn man unterwegs
ist in einem irgendwie öffentlichen Raum
wo man ganz ganz genau überlegen muss
was man tut weil man weiß die
Öffentlichkeit ist völlig intolerant
gegen jeden Normen Verstoß
und das ist natürlich eine massive
Freiheitseinschränkung und dann fragt
man sich wir sind formal ja freier als
wir sehen unsere Geschichte waren aber
rein juristisch sind sehr unglaublich
frei aber fühlt sich für viele Leute
ganz anders an
nee die die die sozusagen die selbst
Zwänge die nehmen immer stärker zu und
jetzt können wir den Bogen schließen
wenn die selbst Zwänge immer stärker zu
leben dann wird das irgendwie in den
Untergrund der eigenen Psyche gedrängt
ja der immer korrekt und sowas sein muss
und nicht irgendwo mal sich da
entspannen oder irgendwas machen kann
und dann lass das früheren oder so das
staut sich an und da hast du eine
Erklärung unter mehreren für unsere
Gereiztheit also da drehen sich das
Ganze doch im Kreis und die Gereiztheit
ist wiederum der Grund dafür dass
normverschlüsse öffentlich sondern man
hat werden aber dieses dieses
hochmoralische das hast ja mittlerweile
auf allen Ebenen ne
das hast du in der Politik das hast Du
gesamtgesellschaftlich dieses moralisch
makellos zu sein ist das etwas für zu
sagen dass vor allen Dingen auch ein
deutsches Phänomen ist oder ist das ein
westliches Phänomen ist es was ist es
wenn ich das so genau wüsste also ich
weiß auf jeden Fall dass früher das
Privatleben von Politikern in der Presse
weitgehend tabu war in Deutschland
man wusste bei Willy Brandt da wurde der
politische Gegner gelästert dass da wohl
ziemlich viele Frauen gab und dass er
auch sehr viel Alkohol getrunken hatte
und das wollen wir so gelegentlich
blitzte das mal irgendwo als Kritik auf
aber ich habe mich sehr gewundert noch
so in den 80er Jahren wo das Privatleben
von Politikern irgendwelche Affären und
eher Probleme und sowas von der
Boulevard Presse in großen klettern
ausgeschlachtet wurden und da habe ich
mir damals noch gesagt das kann in
Deutschland nicht passieren
und ich glaube das erste Mal dass mir
aufgefallen ist es ist jetzt hier
anekdotische Evidenz ja also
wahrscheinlich gibt es noch irgendwie
andere Beispiele oder frühere Beispiele
das sind Politiker wegen seines
Privatlebens in die Schlagzeilen gerät
mal glaube ich als Seehof von
uneheliches Kind hatte und ich meine von
da an so ungefähr wäre es damit
losgegangen dass man auch vor Politiker
nicht Halt gemacht hat und deren
Privatleben erforscht hat und sich Mühe
gegeben hat es zu skandalisieren immer
ja 90 und die Frage ist natürlich ist
das eine gute oder ist das eine
schlechte Entwicklung für die
Betroffenen ist es gruselig und ich kann
daran nicht was ich nur meine ist ist es
nicht sozusagen gerade wenn es um um
Politik geht ist es da möglicherweise
vielleicht dann doch auch Aufgabe von
Medien zu sagen okay der redet am
Sonntag so und in Wahrheit macht er aber
am Freitag ganz andere Dinge
nö also ich messe einen Politiker an dem
was er als Politiker leistet
und nicht an an der Frage ob ein guter
Vater ist
oder was fasziniert öffentlich
inszeniert das meine ich jetzt nicht in
Bezug auf Horst Seehofer ganz generell
hoch spielt und so weiter und dann
stellt sich am Ende raus es gibt keine
Verfehlung die im fremd ist also solche
sozusagen solche krasse krassen
Beispiele hätten also wenn wenn jetzt
Donald trumping gehen würde und würde
puritanische Ehe ideale vertreten oder
sowas alles oder so also sagen wenn sich
jemand auf lächerliche Art und Weise
unglaubwürdig macht
aber ansonsten finde ich es das
Privatleben von Politikern das
unwichtigste überhaupt und das gilt
eigentlich auch für jeden für Künstler
mein Gefühl ist dieses sozusagen an den
Pranger stellen und zwar ohne wirklich
zu wissen was eigentlich Stand der
Ermittlungen ist gibt es
polizeilichermittlungen gibt es eine
Anzeige gibt es eine Anklageschrift gibt
es gab es eine Verhaftung ja was an
etwas anderes ist als eine Festnahme es
geht ja heutzutage auch alles immer
direkt so durcheinander ja der wurde
verhaftet dann geht jeder wohl erstmal
festgenommen so eine große Unterschied
juristisch ja du verhaftet worden bist
oder festgenommen worden bist und klar
ich habe das Gefühl das gibt's so mit
mit Harvey weinst ihn
nicht so ein Fall das Gefühl seitdem
kann man mit so etwas durchkommen
seitdem kann man massive Anklagen
einfach in die Öffentlichkeit bringen
ohne sie genauer belegen zu können was
in dem Fall auch schwer ist aber wenn es
dann glaubwürdig passiert und im Fall
von Weins den
auch noch so ein hervorragendes
Beispiel für für tatsächliche vergehen
so in seiner ganzen Art sozusagen
der Klischee Bösewicht also so so
konserviert
im Film in seinem
eigenständig aufgetragen so und dann
kommt das ins Rollen und plötzlich
stellt sich raus ach guck mal da ist ja
viel viel viel mehr man hat wie weinst
du erinnerst dich war Ronan Ferro der
der Sohn von Woody Allen der das ähm ins
Rollen gebracht hat
und der einfach mal die Geschichte
erzählt hat die offenkundig ganz viele
schon ganz ganz lange wussten und hat
einfach dieses schweige Kartells
zerstört und zerschreddert und
zertrümmert und man muss doch sagen
eigentlich an dem Punkt
der Allgemeinheit und auch der Sache der
Frauen vor allen Dingen einen wirklichen
Dienst erwiesen ohne wahrscheinlich den
letzten perfekten Beweis zu haben wer
weiß zwar also das ist deswegen bin ich
nur sagen der der Grad ist ja sehr sehr
schmal also du hast ja du hast ja das
ist ein schmaler Grad und es ist auch
schwierig deswegen könnte man auch nicht
durch eine veränderte Rechtslage da
jetzt sagen wir müssen den Medien
weniger Spielraum geben und dass man
schneller und leichter klagen kann und
so also das kann seine Vorteile haben
wie du an dem Beispiel gezeigt hast ja
aber ich meine es ist doch dann dem dem
Reifegrad der jeweiligen Journalisten
zuzutragen abzuwägen ob es sich hier
wirklich um einen Fall Winston handelt
oder nicht und wenn das zu einem
Zeitpunkt ist wo man kaum was in der
Hand hat weil eben auch juristisch
manchmal noch nicht mal Anklagen
vorliegen ja das ist klar
das ist die verhältnismäßig ist das
eigentlich das Thema weil das wir reden
ist ist das genau der der wichtige
Gedanke um um den es geht die
Verhältnismäßigkeit stimmt nicht mehr
wie schießen immer komplett übers Ziel
hinaus es gibt nur noch katastrophal
schwarz oder Blüten reine weiße Unschuld
also feiern und großartig finden und
dann aber vom Sockel stoßen und komplett
zerstören sie ihre rammstein
ja ich glaube dass das tatsächlich so
ist und dass diese böse Lust an der
Zerstörung ja dass die sehr sehr
ausgeprägt ist aus dem möglicherweise
aus den von mir vorhin genannten Grund
der unterdrückten
Effekte die man nicht rauslassen kann
und dass man sich bei der Gelegenheit wo
es legitim ist Affekte daraus zu lassen
dass ich auch noch mal richtig gerne
voll daneben benimmt weil einem nichts
passieren kann weil dann entspricht es
der Norm dass man sich dann daneben
benehmen kann und dass man wieder fest
geht und ich finde ich finde das eine so
ungesunde Kultur und wenn wir am Anfang
darüber gesprochen haben wir leben in
dieser gereizten Gesellschaft ich meine
diese Gereiztheit wird ja deutlich immer
nur weiter befördert und weiter
befördert und weiter befördert und wenn
die sich noch weiter steigert ja das ist
im Hinblick auf den sozialen Kit und auf
den sozialen Frieden und so weiter und
unsere Gesellschaft und keine gute
Entwicklung
das Thema das sozusagen Gefühle
plötzlich so unfassbar wichtig geworden
sind und Fakten gar nicht mehr so
entscheidend
als erster messerscharf erkannt der
große Philosoph und hat immer mal gesagt
in der Politik sind Emotionen Fakten
Gefühle sind in der Politik Fakten und
das das und ich glaube er hat dann total
guten Punkt ich weiß noch einmal kurz
zurück zu Jörg Kachelmann wann immer ich
versucht habe ihn zu verteidigen und zu
sagen du pass auf aber juristisch es
geht um das juristische was wirft man
dem Mann vor der ist nichts und er ist
jetzt auch freigesprochen worden der
Satz der immer kam war egal der hat sie
in jedem Fall verdient weil der hat
Frauen schlecht behandelt die aber das
hat doch damit nichts zu tun genau am
Ende bleibt die vorurteilung stehen auch
wenn wenn der Gegenstand für für die
ganze Empörung sich als nicht dich
herausgestellt hat und das ist völlig
richtig was so sagst also wir haben ja
in unserer abendländischen Kultur die
Gefühle über Jahrhunderte und ich aber
Jahrhunderte unterdrückt
und das ging ja bis weit in 20
Jahrhundert hinein noch in den 60er 70er
Jahren ja also die die Anzahl der Männer
die da frei über ihre Gefühle geredet
haben außer beim siebten Bier die waren
ausgesprochen gering Männer redet nicht
über Gefühle Politiker redet und schon
mal gar nicht über Gefühle aber ganz und
gar nicht das hätte sie irgendwie als
schwachen alban dargestellt man musste
sich als Politiker immer als großer
Checker der rational alles durchdringend
und weiß was er tut und man der Tat und
so weiter ja ich habe das glaube ich
auch schon mal erzählt das hat mich sehr
beeindruckt als lothar de Maiziere der
letzte Ministerpräsident der DDR als der
in den Bundestag Einzug in den ersten
gemeinsamen Bundestag nach der
Vereinigung da wurde er gefragt wie
fühlen sie sich
und der fand das war die dämlichste
Frage die mir gestellt worden wenn er
meinte ich bin nicht zum Fühlen hier
hingekommen sondern zum Arbeiten
großartig ist fast so zu ihm das passt
schon wunderbar muss ich dir erzählen
Lothar de Maizière mit dem Stand ich
irgendwann mal in seiner Dusche auf
einem Bootssteg an einem in einem
dunklen See südlich von Berlin und da
war kein Mensch da und wir haben ein
Interview gemacht und plötzlich tritt
aus einer nachbardatsche ein junger Mann
auch auf diesem Boot steht heraus und
ich sag's ihm kennen Sie dies dass Ihr
Nachbar sagt ja ja klar dass der Sohn
von Mielke
das eine schöne Geschichte und plötzlich
auch jemand der nicht berühmt für seine
Gefühle so also in Deutschland
ein großer deutscher Jäger ja genau das
war sein einziger gefühlsausweis nicht
mehr ganz Herr seiner Sinne ich aber ich
liebe doch die Menschen hat gar nicht
verstanden was ihm da was ihm da wieder
fährt
Richard ja spannend dass ein Thema das
ein echt nachdenklich zurücklässt und
wie du sagst irgendwie das Ding wieder
zurück zu drehen
ich glaube dass das nicht geht das kann
ich mir auch nicht vorstellen aber ich
ich fürchte wir werden so nicht
weitermachen können so so geht es auch
nicht irgendwie werden wir einen
besseren Weg finden müssen weil
ansonsten werden die Verhärtungen immer
weiter zunehmen und wir zerlegen uns
irgendwann wirklich gegenseitig und das
kannst du nicht sein ich will besseres
und traurigeres Schlusswort hätte
in diesem Sinne
bis bald tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]